let's go next to Jacob from Nebraska
Jacob from Nebraska you're on the air
hello can you hear me yes I can you do
sound like you're under underground but
I can hear you okay good good I promise
I'm not underground okay as long as
you're not it's fine to sound that way
yeah
how are you doing I'm doing well thank
you
uh so I'm I'm from Nebraska and the
Nebraska Democratic party is notoriously
bad at like existing period okay so how
do you how does the Democratic party
kind of appeal and get beyond the social
issues that really hold the Nebraska
people I think in a place like Nebraska
the I don't think Democrats win by
trying to convince people on social
issues I think Democrats win
particularly at the local level by
showing how the last I mean you could
say 20 30 or even 40 Years of right-wing
economics have economically ravaged many
uh Middle America States I don't know
enough about Nebraska to know exactly
what the source of some of the economic
Strife is but I would if I were working
in Nebraska as a democratic activist I
would I would figure that out and I
would focus almost exclusively on
economic issues and make the social
issues
secondary or even tertiary to campaigns
I I'm not saying it would work but
that's how I would approach Nebraska if
I was trying to elect Democrats
awesome well thank you so much I've been
listening for a long time I've been a
member for a long time I really enjoy
the show so thank you thank you so much
very much appreciate the call